squeeze retrouvent pour le cinquième et
dernier épisode d'inside ces partis
souvenez vous mettez au milieu de ces
gens pendu au il a bougé qui sont encore
vivants apparemment ces gens pendu par
la tête j'allais dire on sait pas
pourquoi ils sont là les poubelles sont
pas avec les autres zombies de l'autre
côté on sait pas non plus pourquoi en
dessous la souvenez vous il ya de l'air
et que l'eau est au dessus de l'air
c'est très bizarre à il ya une porte à
sa part sur un vaisseau spatial
mais non voilà au nec ont du coup je
peux rentrer dedans l'apparemment et
qu'est ce que c'est que ça c'est quoi ce
délire de vaisseau extraterrestre la
chanac emprunt pas est-ce qu'on va enfin
tomber sur des gens qui sont comme nous
qu'ils essaient de s'échapper et on va
former la résistance avec eux c'est ça
la question
on aimerait bien mais bizarrement on n'a
pas trop de sens que ça va arriver où là
ok bon on continue alors et là où il
tourne un truc nettoyait une caméra
c'est quoi ce délire mais qu attend là
je suis saoul ou encore non ça c'est
hyper station d'avoir l'eau au dessus de
nous beaucoup de mal à comprendre le
délire quoi attend au choisi le lait de
l'eau sur demande de ses fantastiques
ah ok le problème c'est que la porte ne
s'ouvre que quand il ya de l'eau
au-dessus h parce que j'atteins palau
l'adc c'est est-ce que je peux atteindre
l'au-delà au lot de la voyez si j'avais
atteindre lola on pourrait aller en face
quand on peut faire puisqu'on est tombé
du coup sûr un truc peut nous aider là
bas une caisse peut-être ouais ça nous
aider ça voilà et bien besoin
oh oh non ils vont chercher les fautes
joué cash
je pense que je me cache que faites vous
et c'est quoi y'a un mec ex-office
[ __ ] mais c'est méga de lourdes boga
il a 8 ans il est pas choqués de ce qui
se passe qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire
avec ces gens ne vont pas les pendre par
la tête dans l'eau quand même un baptême
en fait je peux avancer mais on voit la
gorge et une quasi tout seul ok bon bah
ils ont juste pris les gens la cellule
je passe ils ont faim alors à partir
dollars ok va falloir mettre l'eau pour
pouvoir mettre la caisse sur le bon gros
bords voilà comme ça n'aurait pas ou
arrêtent annoncé bon en fait pas avancer
le vent on va juste la mettre au dessus
de cette plateforme la voilà et en fait
ça va nous permettre d'atteindre l'eau à
temps c'est hyper bizarre ce délire là
on dit qu'il faut une émission télé les
mecs arrêtez de bloquer non s'il vous
plaît que la caisse retombe voilà et
ensuite ça auquel un devrait être bon
c'est parti hop là parfait sa vie n'a
pas de sens dans cette pièce c'est
effrayant mais qu il ya zéro [ __ ] de
son c'est chaud non que dans cette pièce
je vais là ya du saut ouais et là bas
n'est pas pour bref alors on continue
pour elle en bas ou penser s'asseoir on
peut respirer sous l'eau maintenant d'un
c'est quoi ce délire le mec en bas là
ils font quoi en bas là
au d'accord ok ça j'avais oublié que
sous l'eau il n'y a pas de n'y a pas
d'eau celle inverse
ok bon gauthier tout droit écouter alors
pareil là il faudrait qu'on ait de l'eau
bon pour atteindre le bouton je suppose
comment on fait comment on peut faire ça
arrive voilà c'est pareil ça va
permettre de contrôler le lot ok
attendant l'eau et aux eaux mais attends
mais qu on dirait on dirais même plus
des mots a du coup je suis leur sauveur
c'est ça aux voitures et même plus des
humains et la patagonie mon gars ce
terrible bas du coin pour atteindre le
bouton on va faire une [ __ ] de
pyramide ça a passé ni call mais ils
sont morts en fait regarder y en a une
qui tient sa tête là quand même
ok la tête au bout du bras ou en tout
cas vous allez m'aider on va s'échapper
tous ensemble je vous ferai un bon
gâteau au chocolat à la fin de tout ça
allait trop loin encore je peux pas
latin je veux palatin gc maintes et
maintes fois ça marche pas comment faire
pourquoi real et pourquoi lui par terre
il peut il se lève pas qu'est ce qu'il a
il est mort il a même plus de corps
[ __ ] c'est quoi ça
à part baissé de levier de simplement ok
ok j'ai compris j'ai compris ok merci
les amis je vous aime plus tard vous est
cher voilà mon avis c'est là où l'eau
est bas ce jeu pour la tendresse et sa
hockey amical parfait et ce qui me
suivent toujours way monsieur en fait je
pense qu'ils me suivent parce que vous
savez quand j'ai eu la capacité de
respirer sous l'eau
je pense qu'ils m'ont implanté le truc
qui fait que faire une sorte de ils
m'ont apporté le casque en fait en moi
c'est pour ça qu'ils me suivent à mon
avis je vois pourquoi the grudge m'a
aidé un mois je ne mets pas du tout l on
y va aller question de timing
oui au passage on l'a eu en eau a
effectué des poteaux verbe elle devenait
vite avec la portière ferme venez les
amis on va créer une armée on va se
rebeller
ah ok je le sais j'ai cru que c'était
contre nous [ __ ] j'ai eu extrêmement
peur donc du coup je contrôle toutes les
personnes devant lesquels je passe quoi
j'ai le pouvoir en moi je suis l'élu de
choses en moi
mais qui dit c'est que des gens quoi
c'est incroyable vous allez voir mauvais
de l'autre côté selon g moyens les amis
faites moi rêver oui ni quels jeux vous
auriez les gars non je vous aimais
[ __ ] vous aimez tellement ces parages
pas avoir trouvé un moyen légal sans
moyens y en a un qui part en courant là
bas 2 mais qui partent en courant là bas
ok très bizarre ah mais je peux sauter
votre action bas ils vont amortir
suis-je bête les amis suis-je bête alors
que c'est moi
mercy [ __ ] vous est adorable mais
j'aimerais trop les emmener tous avec
moi mais n'y en a pas ou deux qui
veulent venir
[ __ ] nous aurait bien aidé quoi ils
sont très gentils ils amortissent mais
chut qui m'envoie en l'air ils
s'envoient en l'air aussi assez un
ascenseur c'est bon on va les récupérer
pas de panique
allez bonne et les gares
ah merde j'ai juste fait monter [ __ ]
alors ok du coup ils me suivent pas au
dessus c'est ça ouais c'est au dessus de
moi mais non [ __ ] les gars on est trop
con on est très très con en fait ce
qu'il fallait faire comme ça ils
prennent à s'en sort avec moi on arrive
tous en bas tous ensemble c'est tout
beau tout rose
voilà nickel pardon [ __ ] ça fait trop
mal au coeur ils ont l'air tellement
faible j'aime pas du tout les taper
allez on y va
ok je veux que mes gars sur rien ne peut
nous arriver
on va soulever cette porte tous ensemble
allez-y allez-y les gars ok oh [ __ ]
attention a chuté à 7 km alors lui il
voyait sulky tout volaille qui tient sa
tête il fait remballer il ya des gens au
fond qui courent et qui ont l'air
normaux est ce que c'est un bâtiment qui
héberge ce qu'ils ont réussi à s'enfuir
dans la récession
enfin c'est pour tous les mecs on s'en
va très vite c'est promis je vous
libérer de ce mal qui vous ronge peu
qu'on arrive dans ce bâtiment qu'est ce
qui a essayé là on est vraiment dans les
bâtiments jab sion principaux voyez à
base de cigares de pc de tableau où il
disait que les gars c'est très bizarre
elle existe et c'est bon ça hop voilà du
téléphone vous avez on dirait qu'ils
sont tous partis en courant d'un coup
comme s'ils avaient perdu quelque chose
mais quoi de quoi on
s'il eut peur ça la question regardez il
s'enfuit toussaint je rêve pas pourquoi
parce qu'ils savent qu'il ya un élu que
je peux contrôler tout le monde non puis
sa station javel et théoriques tellement
bt rien dit ainsi glauque une caisse qui
leur font à ces gens et film et il ya
des joueurs devant déchets ce qui
regarde ça c'est quoi ce délire mon pote
regardez il court à côté nous l'huile
aucune gêne pour les chefs de plus
monsieur où il pas vous en dire plus sur
ce qui se passe avec jacques tène son
échelle
ok ils ont tous couru pour assister à
quelque chose en fait assisté à quoi
qu'est ce qui se passe et je veux voir
y'a quoi s'il vous plaît on peut pas
voir
ok on va prendre ça va pour atteindre
l'échelle qu'ici rien tous ce curieux
c'est l'effet de foule
y'a du monde à un endroit et aussi tu as
envie d'aller voir ce qui reste ou via
rien là il ya un no comment
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire avec sauter
au dessus oui non à quel jeu compris je
compris pardon il faut juste faire ça
voilà nickel ainsi devoir s'accrocher
aux poteaux qu'est la up
ok on y est attends là on touche au but
là qu'est ce qu'on va pas on va pouvoir
voir ce qui est de l'autre côté un
j'aimerais trop ok c'est parti on
descend tout le monde regarde
qu'est ce qu'il ya là bas au milieu
[ __ ] où on va encore pas voir c'est
chiant on peut voir valu le petit garçon
fait déjà promis de voir juste il
s'enfuit bon ben il a raison il a
totalement raison
c'est lui qui sera dans la cub sinon
c'est que les gens regarderont se trouve
à atterrir là où les gens regardent
justement non non houla faut par peur là
ok
d'accord hp fois les uns je le tente
ayem est celle là on est en train de
s'enfoncer de ouf on va comme ça mec
mais je crois que depuis le début du jeu
si tu regardes à quel point s'enfoncer
on doit être à un kilomètre sous terre -
où là c'est quoi ça mec
c'est quoi ça mais qui tend derval et
voir tout de suite on peut respirer sous
l'eau on a peur de quoi hockey et ça ok
là à regarder la roque est nickel du
coup on va pouvoir atteindre la barre
ici je pense trop à quoi doit servir au
quai à ça ouvre le truc du dessus donc
on va pouvoir aller dans le truc tu es
voir ce qui amène dans ses géniales mais
qu à merde moi même c'est que j'ai pas
le temps d'atteindre le truc ça se
referme comment faire comment faire
est-ce qu'il faut pas lancer et le temps
que ça se lance ce sera bon ouais c'est
ça allez go go go go go des pages et des
pages et des pages et des pages stade
brestois c'est bon on est bon et du coup
ça va directement envoyées dans le trou
c'est parti voilà c'était sûr c'était
sur mac c'est nous qui nous retrouvons
devant les gens [ __ ] c'est horrible à
poil c'est quoi ça
c'est quoi ça mec le bull de de chair
humaine avec des jambes et des bras
ces gens qui ont fusionné alors
attendons vaart
on peut retirer les capteurs ouais c'est
quoi c'est un mec watts
j'arrive pas à comprendre ce que c'est
[ __ ] on peut s'il le souhaite
m'agrippe au passage c'est ignoble
ah ah je me suis fait avoir je suis
dedans mes mecs je contrôle la boule je
perd la boule aussi mes mecs mais qu'est
ce qu'on est devenu est-ce qu'on peut
pas pété genre la vitre derrière
laquelle il ya tout le monde là bas
c'est claude cyr garde est en train de
péter on est en train de l'arracher à
l'est
oh et ont peu bougé
et mon gars mais bon gars mais sa part
en q2 où on s'enfuit bon attendez
hyperpuissant tu me diras assez
terrifiant c'est terrifiant mais non non
non mon con ça marchera pas j'arrache ça
on et 28 ans quand tu peux rien faire
à l ai bien peur j'espère qu'on va
l'écraser la forge ans des gens le
motorisé
on est de retour beach on est renvoyé
mais plutôt comment vous allez
joignez-vous à la boule voulais pas me
joindre à la boule voici qui peuvent la
porter j'ai trop envie de voir attendez
c'est génial l e continuez les gars pas
les gages a besoin de vous [ __ ] ils
nous auront été tellement utiles ces
gens là je pense sauver là où ils sont
que dans ces boules de humaine quand
même non on va pas se mentir
merci les gars c'est répugnant et puis
iorek
salut vous allez bien quoi c'est la
boule humaine c'est la boule de gras
c'est le christ va nous appeler lui qui
allez on y va on fait tout sur votre
passage
on veut s'enfuir
tamek comme on est pour c'est
impressionnant à lotir c'est notre cas
ça va nous aider à grimper là haut de
l'autre côté c'est dégueulasse c'est
cool à la voie non si je m'attendais à
ça les gars tu m'attendais à ça les gens
[ __ ] assez dur de monter sur le truc
on est tellement gros [ __ ] des trois
temps il faut vraiment la poussée contre
le truc est les rébus non elle est
tellement répugnante c'est affreux mike
regarde c'est
allez les gars laisser passer s'il vous
plaît même fait mal pendant 20 ans c'est
vrai qu'il broie rapport
lui carrément aussi le patron c'est le
grand patron mais non qu'est ce que tu
as osé nous faire avec où il a explosé
mais qu il allait exploser
c'était jouissif [ __ ] allez c'est
parti prendre de la vitesse pour péter
le mur de la ba non à pour le soulever
comment on fait pour casser doivent à un
truc voilà ça franchement fin aux
caisses et moi on va sceller de ce bout
de bois pour péter la porte plus tard et
les chemins du mec elle bouge ces gens
par terre alors quoi que c'était
peut-être à nous en fait je dis c'est
pas bon ça c'est avant ce que je fais
non ok je suis débile ya un bouton juste
là je ne l'avais pas vu s'allumer un
bouton mais oui c'est un bouton tout cas
la part de passe péter donc c'est pas un
bouton on est dans le boudin allez vas-y
les bleus les bleus
oui oui ah non non je suis deg
ok on est prêt
c'était bel et bien un mouton dans les
chiens elle est cassée vous je sais qu
est le seul à bord moi je me fais exprès
ah non pas tellement il aboie juste là
ils font pas les malins à banque de
petits fdp
il vous faut que je prenne ma ba en bois
à la traîne elle essaie mois en payant
fait pas le poids
non franchement contre un petit enfant
de 8 ans y avait du monde à aller au
kenya c'est mon a réussit on est dessus
[ __ ] c'est très dur de se dépasser
quand tu fais une tonne et demie c'est
vraiment dur on s'en sortent mieux au
regard des sons bègue
ouais ouais qu'est-ce qui a ouais on
contrôle la boule mon poids que vous
avez créé par contre chaque fois on perd
un peu de de gens de la masse ce qui est
très peu pratique 1 comment nous ça tu
veux pas nous aider là bas le mec
derrière son nom son truc il est né chez
ft qu'il faut remonter à 6 regarder ok
ils nous voient pas il va ouvrir la
porte ce qu'on est là on va le chopper
halsall aux appels temps aux caisses et
descend à tamines bien travers la porte
ok il avait importe merci mec c'est
gentil l ovaire pour nous bon bah écoute
on y va merci c'est sympa on se
souviendra de toi tu fais quoi toi mais
je veux pas tomber dans ce trou mais qu
un tas cru que ça allait marcher pour de
vrai en fait il me qui dit mais john ans
je pense qu'il veut juste que je me bats
écoutez on va à à ces hyper satisfaisant
de voir ci-contre y passer un si petit
trou comme ça à carnac sexuelle tout ce
que je dis trou qui lui sexuelles
adoptées tout de suite on a la caisse à
me permettre de ces du feu là aurait
évité quand même ça sert à quelque chose
à abala juste au-dessus [ __ ] on va
l'envoyer là haut up claque hockey et ça
qu'est ce que c'est juste une lampe
c'est up à ana pt la lampe et du coup ça
sauf parfait on va y aller cette caisse
ça peut nous servir les amis moi
j'aimerais bien qu on recroise notre
pote the grudge qui nous a sauvés quand
même et qu'on lui dise merci quoi qu'on
lui fasse une bise je sais pas c'est un
peu grâce à lui qu'on est là à orillia
du soul mais on va pas se brûler mec
mais non mais non mais faut pas faut pas
qu'on brûle le mec assis il va brûler
l'abomination du coup qui a été créée
vous pensez non je pense pas à temps je
pense qu'il faut envoyer la caisse
dedans c'est que ça fait quelque chose
ah ok elle est en feu il va falloir amer
ok par l'envoyé tu seras d'accord ok go
find dans le tour qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure il y avait marqué le feu dessus
sauf qu'il ya une série d'obstacles un
voyage rivés aux attentions à l'eau aux
plats
oui au cvo hommes boxaient à c'est
génial ramène la flamme olympique mon
pote à temps c'est dur quand je pense
pas c'est sympa
ah non à pita faisait pas une autonomie
on aurait pu se déplacer plus vite
oui avec l'élan alors là c'est passé
mais à la perfection
ok on y va c'est parti on va pouvoir
l'envoyer dans le truc qui réclament du
feu j'ai aucune et ses affaires mais je
pense que ça va être pas mal
allez c'est parti ce qui va se passer
grosse explosion la peau retrouve du
coup ouais t'as monga cette boule de
gras le kyste humain je peux en remet
pas moyen mais du coup le petit garçon
il est dans la boule et il est bien lui
où il a vraiment fusionner avec ça que
je me demande alors qu'il faudrait qu'on
fasse là bas voilà on va prendre ça on
va s'en servir immédiatement
et on va pouvoir atteindre le petit
frigo tussac faut attendre je pense à
achever les bruits val lâcher c'est ça
ça me fait marrer devant ce gros trip
hop comme ça allez les mecs là c'est bon
oui on va tout péter
comme des cons mon gars ça fait moins
les malins on se retrouve le côté du mur
rien
j'aimerais avoir mené de ça quand même
wen s'est vu qu'on est extrêmement gros
il faut vraiment pousser les trucs
jusqu'au mur peut pas sauter hop c'est
parti je me demande comment ça va se
terminer
si on va tenter ce genre ça va marcher
avec alain flausch de mètres en dessous
ok ok faut l'acte ok alors attends je
sais bien active le active et l'eau
merci les gars ok on y est oui oui on
est passé c'est beau aulas est ce que
des gens tous américains
regardez c'est que des gens ok on joue
avec nous à les bâtards bons va
continuer elles vont à coup en arrière
on n'a rien du tout ok comment on fait
pour choper le truc hockey du coup ils
nous ont piégés
c'est ça on se retrouve dans l'eau
et dans le noir c'est ça d'accord bon
bien trouver un petit trou on va pas se
mentir ça regardez ces deux brèches
non non si cynique elle pouvait arracher
un deuxième voilà ça dégage et on va
pouvoir passer à al ayyat une grille
regardez c'est de ce côté là hop là on
peut se barrer on veut à la lumière pas
se mentir on va vers la lumière on
espère un jour sortir de ce gros corps
flasque et redevenir billère sont de 8
ans c'est un peu chaud vous comme lui
pour un petit garçon de 8 ans qu'est bon
côté du chemin et j'espère qu'on s'en
sort franchement ça va craquer ça oui
oui oui
métro léger à mai du coup on va pouvoir
courir super vite et péter tous comment
regarder attention gros talent grèce
lancer parfait mais non sur les sorties
mec mais non mais mondiale raser la
forêt mais non mais non
c'est bon on s'en est sorti mais non on
est on est on n'est pas en train de
mourir là quand même
qu'est-ce qui se passe
on est mort
c'est ça
c'est la fin ok mais je n'arrive pas à
comprendre si on est bien vivant ou pas
en fait on bouge encore donc je pense
juste que ça y est on s'en est sortis
quoi on s'en est sorti maintenant on va
essayer de trouver un emploi d'avoir une
vie normale mais avec cette tête c'est
compliqué quoi ça finisse comme ça et le
je recommence aussitôt ça j'aimerais
totalement que vous me disiez vos
interprétations de cette fin si on se
transforme en cailloux ou si juste
l'enfant est libre ou 6 et on est libre
mais on est mort dans la foulée je sais
pas je suis perdu je suis perdue chez
mousty en tout cas c'est la faute ce qui
plaît bercés l'erreur sévices étaient
assez ou [ __ ] c'est vraiment des jeux
qui font hyper plaisir des bons jeux
indé comme ça pas très long mais qui
sont vraiment des master piece
franchement cette tombe bien c'était
incroyable graphiquement c'était
incroyable aussi c'était très très
malsain très très mince un très très
gore et je pense c'est un peu ce que
vous avez qui fait c'est que on est
finalement terrifié on est horrifié de
conjoint jeu mais pas pour les mêmes
raisons que quand je intéresse d'après
10 là c'est juste l'ambiance les
intentions des gens les les attitudes
des gens les décors qui sont vraiment
bizarre je peux vous mentir j'ai tout de
suite cherché des explications sur le
cette fin je suis hyper intrigué je suis
pas très bas si vous avez des
interprétations n'était pas les laisser
en commentaire je suis curieux de lire
tout ça est de voir ce que vous pensez
et puis écoutez je vous dis à très dans
une prochaine vidéo merci parce qu'il
est plus on ne refera peut-être un avant
la fin des vacances d'été portez vous
bien à très vite je suis tout ému et
hollande pis